a
[Música]
ah
louis glow la poetisa estadounidense que
ganó el premio nobel de literatura es
profesora de literatura en la
universidad de yale tiene 77 años es de
nueva york' y ha tenido una
impresionante carrera en el mundo de las
letras anteriormente obtuvo el premio
pulitzer y también el premio nacional
del libro y su escritura se basa
básicamente en temas de la condición
humana la vida familiar la infancia e
incluso la muerte es la decimosexta
mujer en obtener este premio nobel de
literatura y en entrevistas anteriores
había asegurado que ella quería seguir
viviendo después de la muerte algo pues
que claramente se cumplirá con este
reconocido galardón se espera que el día
de mañana el premio nobel también sea
entregado en las categorías de paz y
también de económica
[Música]
el escritor y poeta venezolano rafael
cadenas figura este año entre la lista
de favoritos de quienes escriben en
castellano para optar al premio nobel de
literatura cadenas quien recientemente
cumplió 90 años ya ha ganado el premio
reina sofía de poesía iberoamericana el
premio internacional federico lorca y el
premio fil de literatura y lenguas
romances los más importantes galardones
de literatura en español el escritor
venezolano empezó a hacer poesía desde
muy joven su éxito como poeta se
extendió por toda latinoamérica a partir
de 1963 tras la publicación de su obra
de ruta su último libro publicado es
contestaciones de 2018 una serie de
aforismos con los que responde citas de
personajes como el che guevara en
venezuela- un concurso de poesía para
jóvenes lleva el nombre de rafael
cadenas como homenaje a su trayectoria
en la literatura nacional su obra lo
sitúa como uno de los grandes exponentes
de la poesía hispanoamericana
[Música]
si la academia sabe lo que es bueno para
ellos tendrán que elegir a jamaica
kincaid dijo a afp jon whitman el editor
de cultura del diario sueco dagens
nyheter y la autora nacida en antigua y
barbuda en 1949 y profesora de harvard
escribió entre otras novelas
autobiografía de mi madre mi madre nació
en el momento en que yo nací comienza su
narración kingate se encuentra en la
lista de favoritas a la que también
pertenece maryse condé ganadora del
premio nobel alternativo en 2018
galardón paralelo al de la academia
sueca que surgió hace dos años cuando la
institución estuvo envuelta en un
escándalo sexual y de invitaciones a la
prensa protagonizado por jean claude
arnold marido de una de los miembros del
comité de selección ambas autoras son
exponentes de la denominada literatura
poscolonial y retratan en sus universos
caribeños los abusos que padecen las
mujeres así como también las clases
subordinadas en términos de la teoría de
gaia trick chakra torch
[Música]